I wanted to start with polynomial is
actually very convened that we'd began
that way because that's where these
names come from admitted evens
but what you think about it there are
other kinds of functions that have
nothing to do with polynomials that have
these same kinds of symmetry pink or in
turn to you right now think back to Tom
one second part I even alluded to it we
were drawing this why is it kind of
function D node that has a symmetry
disease they take us one why cuz the
projects okay keep all with me at this
time as you can see because symmetries
important I want to draw both hands King
Joffrey
what kind of symmetry is connected yeah
why okay yeah is that all you're even
could use a good time I'll come back to
this in second I'll give you a more
technical definition for what botanist
and even is are I just want to explore
the pictures first the short answer is
approximately there's a couple revenging
data there's one of them and there's
another one of the music okay but X
there connects it's pretty terrible
context but you get the idea what
customer cheese's have look at odd and
look at you which one is it
can you rotate the ceramic attempting if
I if I grab these and and then just spin
it around will I get the same thing you
won't will you get this but upside down
okay because this part here will rotate
180 degrees on the bottom okay so
rotational symmetry is not it instead
what you want to do is to rely down
right in fact this is something I
appealed to back when we were doing the
expansions right I said look this codex
part and this codex part causes negative
X as a word are exactly the same so this
is also an even function right think
what's another trig function which has a
different kind of surgery you just
cosine how that sign do you see how sine
also has symmetry but if the kind that
you don't get by reflection is it if you
reflected it across the Y axis like we
did with this then you're not going to
get the same kind of shape that you're
going to get negative sine X right so
therefore we would pay this one and
unfamiliar just like y equals execute
okay now I'm just giving you a visual
definition so far now I need to give you
a proper rigorous definition and it
depends on this function don't click
notation okay
so this will do you know something a
formal definitions
this will be a bit tricky because it's
over all weekend that we didn't
emphasize add money but I want you to
think back to your lesson with the
Dennis on Friday okay do you remember he
was talking to you about transforming
graphs or translating them shifty all
that kind of thing one of the things he
talked about was reflection like this
right how do you reflect the graph
horizontally what do you do to it how do
you change it like a day listen if I
were to take this guy which I think
everyone knows what it looks like
the return negative to a bigger tree so
there you go there's that graph what
moves me to - he actually took this
exactly exactly don't want me to change
it from being on that let your time to
reflect it across to the right hand side
what do we do we need some negatives
right because negatives are about
opposite direction the thing you have to
do to this is that is exactly put in
this negative x right and then you also
put in this negative x do you remember
that we actually did on dazzles it did
on the board and sure enough you get
this shape now you get the idea okay now
what is this that he has done from here
to here heats up to every air with our
negative x so how would you plug that in
function notation by the time
okay so now we can use this to talk
about odd and to even symmetry but
somewhere even 51st for even functions
what makes an even function and even
function is that the function is equal
to itself if you are to horizontally
reflective let me say that again because
it's very concise notation that's why
we're using it but it packs in so much
punch a function is equal to itself even
if you reflect it horizontally we can
just go see you guys both of them right
you're reflecting from luckily same
thing we could cause X right you
reflected horizontally safely okay now
we can answer the question y equals x do
you see why it's what even symmetry
right it has reflectional symmetry but
not in the right way
it's off at an angle do you notice that
what gives me truly even symmetry is if
it's this one axis X equal zero that's
where I have my symmetry X equal zero
okay so this is what an even function
use f of X equals F of negative x
quickly just for yourself test it out
like do you see why why because x
squared gives you this easily this right
what is F of negative x in this case you
well before I get the extra lock and
speak about the substitutions right
everywhere you see an X you substituted
for negative x and then of course you
swear it was there step that's x squared
because your double negatives cancel
which is why double negatives cancel you
see why all of these guys are going to
have that same symmetry because they
have an even number of negative signs
make them a check that's an even
function
what's an odd function now we have some
grass on the board that I'm going to use
to help us understand the spring here's
what I want you to picture if you get it
on function like say this guy's excuse
me I want you to picture you've had two
I will draw it for you what happens when
you flip it horizontally
that's what happens when take executes
and we flip it horizontally this guy
right here that used to be in the first
quadrant is going to come over to the
second quadrant I'll put the
horizontally right this way that's right
I'm going to get this shape your grid
this pipe it used to be the third
quadrant is going to come over to that
fourth quadrant so there is there's my
new graph right so the original is FX
here is F of negative x we flip this
horizontally
do you notice that what we've got is
exactly the same and if we had lifted
vertically to notice that that's
reasoner right I actually described it
by moving this guy over here look like
that and this guy over here like that
does that make sense but now what you're
looking at is just the same as if I'd
said they take this guy slip it down
this way instead oh you see it's the
same and it's the same over here so if
you're popular how would I describe that
with function notation slipping
horizontally is the same as flipping
very how I write is vertical smile so
that means I want to supply some word
under here so when you come back to this
in a week and we like what the Dickens
does this mean that this is a horizontal
reflection
as an L right if you had a none function
a horizontal reflection will give you
exactly the same result and the vertical
one and the reason why is because that
180-degree rotation
do you remember we talked about that a
180 degree rotation is exactly the same
as taking something sitting horizontally
and then flipping it vertically that's
exactly the same as 180 degree rotation
okay so that's why these things are the
same put together is a 180 degree
rotation
I should say around the origin but you
give you okay right so can you see why
we prove that x squared is an even
function how we prove that a X cubed is
an odd function how would you do it
all you have to do is come back to this
deposition that's why I definitions are
so important rather than something like
basically draw a picture and say I kind
of looks like that this formal
definition huge sort of max it out for
me if this is what FX is then tell me
what F of negative x is knowledge a
question just what do I do
everywhere I see X I'm gonna substitute
in for that that's what it is right so
this is negative x times negative x and
negative x so how many [ __ ] are there
three two of which will cancel leaving
you me just in one right look at me go
by definition that's our vertical for
business that's negative f of X so this
means it's an odd function once we've
ended there does that make sense you
will notice an important thing that you
will simply remember back from trig
identities if I want to prove that this
is the case I don't write this as my
first wine I write this as my last one
does that make sense yes so just watch
out for that don't begin here this is
where you should end so I just think
about what the function is and I
substituted negative x if it's even or
if it's odd then you'll see what comes
out the other one last question before I
set you work I began disloyal verses
with this guy what kind of symmetry does
he have isn't it odd function
not known functions right because if you
go in and you put in daily events like I
did up here you don't get minus FX back
do you you don't you don't get this this
is what altimetry would be is it an even
function what has it even powered up in
it x squared but it is not an even
function why not
what would I need for it to being even
functions
here's my definition of attachment right
let me try if f of X is that that sdmx
will be x squared minus 5x plus 6 degree
is in that the original function sorry
so it has a kind of symmetry it's just
neither of these and in fact you'll find
the vast majority of functions doesn't
fit nicely into the exact pattern but
when they do happen you can notice it's
like structure and you can do lots of
really important things when we get to
calculus let's talk okay